this morning we're launching a new
series called pay attention we'll be
looking at the role technology plays in
our lives in a different way its impact
on our ability to focus and how we can
recapture our attention from the
technology that distracts us the average
American spends 5 hours a day on mobile
devices
that's 76 full days a year for some
that's wonderful we learn we make human
connections and experience wonder but
devices also shred our ability to focus
so what do we need to do to keep this
balanced to start our process we wanted
to establish a baseline so our cameras
followed me home to document a typical
Saturday where I use my phone and
computer and the second Saturday which
is not typical at all where I use no
technology by the end of our series we
hope to find the happy medium between
the two my person or action with mankind
with any other sentient life was with my
phone so now I'm opening clear tune
which allows me to guitar
today I have a big piece of writing to
do so I need to find some time to be
focused after about 45 minutes the
normal itchiness of writing or working
you can escape from those by well let's
just check in with the email detour lead
to detour the detour and then suddenly
you're in Albuquerque then there's that
digital siren call the interruption
online you can go off down a rabbit hole
that tells you and hear I'm now getting
another oh no this thing is going off
again oh did you hear that come come on
dirt
let's go for walk come on a notification
on your phone or even the anticipation
of one releases dopamine somebody liked
an Instagram photo the chemical
responsible for controlling the brains
reward and pleasure centers if you take
24 hours in a day and let's say that I'm
sleeping eight hours a day that leaves
16 hours my phone has just interrupted
me with a text so we keep coming back
for more on this Saturday I picked up
the phone 86 times using it for more
than four hours that's in addition to a
few hours on the computer there it is by
itself in digital time out for the whole
day my phone cannot touch it it's 10:20
in the morning I've wanted to send these
messages or check things this is
probably about as I'm bad of a dozen
times the idea behind this is no devices
in here at all dr. Michael Bayne runs
the mindfulness program at the
University of Pennsylvania I'm a big
proponent of mindfulness for things like
this because mindfulness is really a
process that trains your attention to be
more stable
he says when our attention is wobbly we
no longer make a choice to stay focused
we automatically pick up our phones
today I've gone without technology and
increasingly over the course of the day
I've had this hunted
feeling this itchy feeling what's
happening to me
you're stepping in the way of a habit
it's hard the thing that devices take
from us is the ability to have a full
complete focus
so when attention is drawn here and
there over and over again it becomes
fragmented and our experience of the
whole world becomes fragmented in that
same way